I hate being cold like I'm from the
desert and cold is just not something
that I'm into actually has kind of like
a eighty bruised knee and I'm secretly
hoping that it's gonna magically fix it
my biggest fear would be like my fingers
getting really cold and like falling off
I went skydiving before I think I can do
this
so basically what you guys will be doing
today is really going to chamber its
negative 220 degrees somewhere
associated with this could be frostbite
skin burns and irritations but we don't
let you go in for long enough for that
even to happen so we're going to put you
in for a safe amount of time it's a
minute and a half minute Nick hop sounds
like a very short time but it'll be the
longest but I honestly feel like I'm
like in line for a roller coaster
ready oh she's ready
well I got I'm getting naked per video
another day at work what if I see my
dance wall
turn it on now I don't think I've ever
been this cold in my life
always end early try to stick it out
move around a little bit
very cool so now we're going into the
cryo m3 which is the meat locker version
of the cryo chamber the cult happens in
here actually when you open this door
you get welcomed by this big cloud of
cold air again - - 20 below so who's
first at the human test there was
something nice and comforting about
being in there oh yeah oh yeah well I
can kind of feel the mucus in my nose
crisp up
hello Canaries that's cool I like that a
lot 3 2 1
time is up to the chamber I can't speak
my brains frozen there she goes I think
we all know hooded whistles ooh who is
one or the other one worse I think this
one usually I can't touch my toes
bingo that's cryo for being outside in
Boston in the winter for an hour was
worse than being in there for a nap
it was by far the coldest that I've ever
been in my entire life
it was definitely invigorating and
refreshing I would do it again I mean if
I see a change or feel a really big
difference I would definitely want to
come back so maybe this weekend
you